if you look deep into the night sky you
see stars and if you look further you
see more stars and further galaxies and
further more galaxies but if you keep
looking further and further eventually
you see nothing for a long while and
then finally you see a faint fading
afterglow and it's the afterglow of the
Big Bang now the Big Bang was an era in
the early universe when everything we
see in the night sky was condensed into
an incredibly small incredibly hot
incredibly roiling mass and from it
sprung everything we see now we've
mapped that afterglow with great
precision and when I say we I mean
people who aren't me we've mapped the
afterglow with spectacular precision and
one of the shocks about it is that it's
almost completely uniform 14 billion
light years that way and 14 billion
light years that way it's the same
temperature now it's been 13 billion
years since that Big Bang and so it's
got faint and cold it's now two point
seven degrees but it's not exactly two
point seven degrees it's only two point
seven degrees to about ten parts in a
million over here it's a little hotter
and over there it's a little cooler and
that's incredibly important to everyone
in this room because where it was a
little hotter there was a little more
stuff and where there was a little more
stuff we have galaxies and clusters of
galaxies and superclusters and all the
structure you see in the cosmos and
those small little inhomogeneities xx
parts in a million those were formed by
quantum mechanical Wiggles in that early
universe that were stretched across the
size of the entire cosmos that is
spectacular and that's not what they
found on Monday what they found on
Monday is cooler so here's what they
found on Monday imagine you take some
hot or you take a bell and you whack the
Bell with a hammer what happens it rings
but if you wait that ringing phase
and fades and fades until you don't
notice it anymore now that early
universe was incredibly dense like a
metal way denser and if you hit it it
would ring but the thing ringing would
be the structure of space-time itself
and the hammer would be quantum
mechanics what they found on Monday was
evidence of the ringing of the
space-time of the early universe what we
call gravitational waves from the
fundamental era and here's how they
found it those waves have long since
faded if you go for a walk you don't
wiggle those gravitational waves in the
structure of space aren't totally
invisible for all practical purposes but
early on when the universe was making
that last afterglow the gravitational
waves put little twists in the structure
of the light that we see so by looking
at the night sky deeper and deeper in
fact these guys spent three years on the
South Pole looking straight up through
the coldest clearest cleanest air they
possibly could find looking deep into
the night sky and studying that glow and
looking for the faint twists which are
the symbol the signal of gravitational
waves the ringing of the early universe
and on Monday they announced that they
had found it and the thing that's so
spectacular about that to me is not just
the ring though that is awesome
the thing that's totally amazing the
reason I'm on this stage is because what
that tells us is something deep about
the early universe it tells us that we
and everything we see around us are
basically one large bubble and this is
the idea of inflation one large bubble
surrounded by something else
this isn't conclusive evidence for
inflation but anything that isn't
inflation that explains this will look
the same this is a theory an idea that
has been around for a while and we never
thought we'd really see it for good
reasons we thought we'd never see killer
evidence and this is killer evidence the
really crazy idea is that our bubble is
just one bubble in a much larger roiling
pot of universal stuff we're never going
to see the stuff outside but by going to
the South Pole and spending three years
looking at the detailed structure of the
night sky we can figure
out that we're probably in the universe
that looks kind of like that and that
amazes me thanks a lot
[Applause]